President Trump says you can't go wrong
with his final four Supreme Court
candidates the president will announce
his nominee tonight sources tell CBS
News the contenders are appeals court
judges Amy Coney Barrett Thomas Hartman
Brett Kavanaugh and Raymond Catholic mr.
Trump is focusing most closely on
Cavanaugh and Hardiman according to Jan
Crawford Senate Majority Leader Mitch
McConnell told the president that
Hardiman and Catholic may be easier to
confirm leonard leo is executive vice
president of the federalist society a
conservative lawyers group he's
currently on leave Leo advises President
Trump on judicial nominations and helped
create the list of candidates for the
president he joins us from Washington
good morning good morning when was the
last time you talked to the president
and he's has he made a decision spoke to
him yesterday he had not yet made a
decision indicated that he wanted to
make a decision tonight
at last night or this morning so that's
what we're waiting for and I'm sure
he'll announce this evening of course
and maybe there'll be a bit of a
heads-up he's had these names for a
while you helped him craft them he's
known about this issue he talked about
it during the campaign what's he waiting
now and what why is anything still up in
the air well he spent a pretty
significant amount of time over the
weekends asking questions talking to
people thinking about this further this
is a really big decision for him as you
may remember he spent a good part of his
campaign talking about this issue this
was a big reason why people voted for
him so he wants to get it right like
Neal Gorsuch what does getting it right
mean what kinds of questions are on his
mind again this is this has been on his
mind for a while so what's what's still
puzzling him well there are three things
that he looks at you know one is being
extraordinarily well qualified and
that's you know looking at the record
but also he wants someone who's going to
be courageous independent and fair and a
lot of that has to do with you know
talking to people who know these
nominees talking to people who've known
them for years getting a sense of how
they've how they've dealt with difficult
issues in their career you really have
to get to know somebody and that
requires not only an interview but
thinking about what happened in that
interview and obviously talking to lots
of people in the in the legal profession
and elsewhere let's go through some of
the names first Thomas Hardiman sources
say the president is somewhat enamored
with his biography as someone who is not
from one of the Ivy League's who paid
for for college by being a taxi driver
he was one of the runners-up with the
Neal Gorsuch in the past what are some
of his strengths well first of all he's
been both an appeals judge and a trial
judge for a number of years has many
judicial opinions he's demonstrated a
commitment to interpreting laws
according to their text in their
original meaning he has a very
compelling narrative as you mentioned
having come from pretty modest or you
know a modest background and having
worked his way through college so I
think he's someone who would appeal to
many people in our country and Brett
Kavanaugh also a judge worked for was
solicitor worked for George W Bush some
have suggested that he has too long of a
paper trail to be confirmed your take on
that well look judge Cavanaugh is really
one of the most distinguished jurists in
the country he's written over 300
opinions he looks a lot like Neal
Gorsuch in the sense that he cares very
deeply about respecting and enforcing
limits on government power I think he's
someone who again is very much like the
Gorsuch model which the president's been
focusing on Leonard Leo you helped him
put the list together who is your
favorite all the people the president
looking at a great okay it's very
exciting all right Thank You leo thanks
so much CBS News will bring you a
special report when President Trump
announces his nominee for the Supreme
Court tonight Jeff Glor will anchor from
Washington you can see it at 9:00 p.m.
Eastern 8:00 central right here on CBS